this is the first question
uh i promised to get to it last week uh
as a lesbian who has never conformed to
sex stereotypes i am curious what makes
real trans
woman is not something to identify into
live not by lies
and that last of reference to um both
sulci nation's essay and perhaps also
rod drear's book of the same name that
we talked about extensively in episode
50.
um so um
this is this is a conversation for uh
longer than
a q a and um i
think we may go there a little bit in
the letter wiki that abigail schreier
and i do
maybe a little bit but i would say this
that
sex is based on what type of gamete you
produce right
if it's small and zippy versus large and
sessile you're male versus female
what sex you are is determined
in uh mammals by your chromosomes
which then affect things um beyond your
um your steroid hormones but the steroid
hormones being sort of primarily
androgens or primarily estrogens or
progesterone
being highly descriptive of what of
whether or not you're going to become
male or female
and so you have you know you have
chromosomal sex
you have anatomical and physiological
sex which is largely described by
endocrinology although it turns out that
the actual chromosomes the actual x and
y at the 23rd location
also even absent differences
in in hormone levels um can
affect um sex like how
you manifest your primary and secondary
sex characteristics
um and then you also have ways that your
sex
is revealed in your in your brain
which includes not just you know like
the white matter and gray matter but
also how it is that you perceive what
sex you are
we are so complicated and there are so
many things going on
that it shouldn't be surprising to us
that under some conditions
one or more of those systems is not
entirely consistent
and so that that is my sort of very
short
uh description you know when when one or
more of those systems
is not consistent with all the rest
you will have someone who
looks one way and is in fact one sex but
feels
so certain in themselves that they are
the other thing
um that is not um you know that that is
what gender dysphoria is that you
you have a mismatch and generally
you know it's talked about between sort
of your brain sex what what it is that
your brain is assuring you of as opposed
to the other demarcations of sex which
are
of course the actual biological sex that
you are
yep um i would say you know this
gets more difficult to deal with um the
more uh
trans is taken to be um
normal i don't mean there's anything
abnormal about it because i actually
don't think there is i think it's got
his
historical roots well it's anything
super rare can be considered abnormal
well i don't want to say that okay so
the problem is
abnormal carries the connotation of
um dysfunction and i
i think there is real trans in the sense
that we see it reflected in
many cultures it's built in it's ancient
um which doesn't rule out the
possibility of arriving there through
dysfunction in
modern times be it you know hormones in
the environment you know
or hormone mimics or whatever um however
my point is just simply there is
i don't think being trans is easy and
that is to say that at the point that
the discomfort
of um living within the sex to which you
were born
is so great that you are ready to
confront
the complexity difficulty
of transition then the point is you're
actually saying something about the
degree to which things feel off and that
you'd actually you know prefer to
confront that
process of transition than to remain
where you were
so to the extent that we are going to
valorize transition and encourage people
to think
that any sense that they have the things
that are off or definitely an indication
that you're trans
then this loses all meaning but um
and in fact that's that's really the key
thing that i want to say is that
you know we all all of us who have grown
up in
modern times have dealt with the
confusion
of living in a world that is not well
suited to us
right it isn't and so the number of
people who are going to have the sense
something is definitely profoundly off
and i need a solution that number of
people is going to be high
and therefore the number of people who
will say i know what it is
i don't much like these sex roles that
are inflicted on me i had no choice
about them and you know what
i actually think i prefer that other
thing number of people who will think
that that's a solution until they've
actually attempted it and discovered
actually you know what
things are just generally off because
the world is not well structured for
people
yeah no it's it's a it's a perfect storm
where all the lunacy of postmodernity
meets all of the market force and
ability to do
and both of these things really do great
damage
of big pharma and you you just get these
two things together
in this perfect storm in in in trans and
you know i often would
say you know it's trans rights activists
as opposed to
truly trans people truly trans people
being a much tinier
much tinier population with presumably
some slight overlap
between those and you know sort of
everyone else who's
who's doing some combination of activism
and cosplay and larping
and benefiting from pharmaceutical
intervention the likes of you know the
we do know many of the downstream
effects of a lot of the pharmaceuticals
both the hormone blockers and the
puberty blockers and the actual
cross-sex hormones that are being used
and we don't know most of them i
guarantee you but the combination of
reality is what i say it is and i will
i'm going to use um the market-driven
product over here about which we know
nothing
and uh the makers of which will not
protect me in any way once the
downstream effects are discovered
comes together just perfectly in this
really
really terrible moment so that is not to
say
again that there isn't some very tiny
number of people who are
really legitimately trans and who are
better off who live
more complete lives most of which don't
have anything to do with their transness
from being able to transition and i
think
maybe to say this in a way that's
clearer than i've ever
said it before hopefully there is
something
about the desire to avail oneself
of scientific help
in transitioning while denying the
implications of scientific study with
respect to things like sex and gender
one ought to be obligated to one side of
this either you're postmodern and you
really think
the science stuff is just a posture that
people strike in which case
you're wrong but you're entitled to be
wrong in that way
or you believe in science and you both
want its help but then are in some sense
obligated to the method for figuring out
what's true and what isn't
and um it is i think driving many of us
crazy to watch
a desire for science a la carte
right i want the drugs i want
uh the surgery i do not want to have to
listen to another word
about the difference between the sexes
or the binariness of sex or gametes or
any of those things
down with trade-offs
[Laughter]
yeah down that the utopians who aren't
up for the fact of trade-offs are a real
problem and
not listening to them would be a very
good idea but all you have to do is sit
down with trade-offs and
they're done i guess so yeah
you